et nous sommes avec kevin malacarne
fondateur d'actions soit infirmée
françois krakowski médecins spécialistes
de santé publique bonsoir messieurs et
merci d'être avec nous ce soir
selon l'agencé européenne du médicament
30 thrombose ont été observées dans sa
zone de surveillance alors que plus de
cinq millions de personnes ont reçu le
vaccin d'astrazeneca françois cravans
qu'est ce que ça vous semble anecdotique
est ce que c'est le lot finalement de
tout traitement médical de toute
vaccination ou bien est ce qu'il ya des
réseaux en sérieuse de s'interroger bien
je pense que c'est c'est plutôt commun
c'est à dire comme l'a dit à l'ats il ya
moins de cas chez les vaccinés que j'ai
la population générale
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que enfin ma
vie lance c'est à dire à surveiller
effets indésirables des médicaments
on parle de d'imputabilité et c'est à
dire qu' on essaie de corelio tant que
fai re la survenue d'un effet
indésirable à la prise du médicament
mais on établit jamais de causalité
servent un effet indésirable déjà dire
oui on est sûr à 100 ans que cet effet
est dû à la prise du médicament ça il
faut des études bien que plus vaste pour
vraiment avoir des données qui soit
significative sur la survenue d'un ou
d'une malade a prise d'un médicament là
les chiffres sont trop faibles pour
pouvoir dire que la prise du vaccin
augmente le risque de revenus de ce type
d'événement voilà est officiellement à
ce jour aucun lien de cause à effet n'a
été trouvé entre l'administration du
vaccin d'astrazeneca et c4 thrombose
c'est ce que déclare à la fois l' oms et
l'agencé européenne du médicament elles
se veulent rassurantes sur l'utilisation
du vaccin kevin malacarne est ce que
justement ça vous rassure ses
déclarations oui moi moi je suis pas
inquiet par rapport à ce que je
j'entends est ce que je lis à travers
les médias les à l'étude pour l'instant
était relativement rassurantes sur
l'utilisation d'oeufs
de ce produit est de toute façon les
instances ont évidemment à l'écouté
comme disait françois krakowski tout à
l'heure à la ja système de
pharmacovigilance vont se dire que tout
des problèmes sont remontées à sur
dirigeante et s'il y avait un problème
notoire qu'il était qu'ils étaient
repérés et bien tout de suite le vaccin
n'importe quel médicament
une alerte qui serait donnée et
l'administration seraient stoppés
ce qui n'est pas le cas pour l'instant
alors effectivement il ya pas mal de
petits effets secondaires mais ils sont
bénins et ils sont évidemment largement
inférieur aux bénéfices qu'apporte le
vaccin et à toutes les vies sauvées et
toutes les paires les patients
hospitalisés évité grâce à la
vaccination
alors va revenir sur ce bénéfice risque
comme si je vous comprends bien vous
n'êtes pas de ceux qui estiment qu'il
faut qu'il faudrait suspendre
astrazeneca en france alors je suis de
ceux qui disent qu'il faut accélérer bon
je pense que là dessus de toute façon on
fait le maximum avec les doses que qui
nous sont distribués par les différents
laboratoires bon je suis content je
viens d'apprendre que la quatrième place
à johnson & johnson l'avait autorisée
par par agence européenne donc c'est une
bonne chose ça vous permettent encore
d'augmenter la cadence et et puis ils
cherchent à faire du mieux possible que
le plus vite possible
françois carde travail quel intérêt
médical est ce qu'il y aurait à
suspendre dans l'hexagone
l'administration de ce vaccin
astrazeneca
c'est très simple j'envoie j'en vois
aucun à ce jour une épidémie qui a qui
implique tout ce que l'on connaît depuis
maintenant un an tant sur le plan
sanitaire avec un monde qui devient
quand même extrêmement important une
pénalisation de nos vies à tous privés
comme professionnels à une pénalisation
de notre économie
puis hier aujourd'hui aucun intérêt pour
nous a privés de ce vaccin
sur sur quelques remontées de fermat
plusieurs ski pas encore aurélie a eu la
causalité ou à des chiffres suffisamment
élevée par ' dire qu'ils sont cyniques
et significatif voilà en tout cas et
qu'ils ont avec un réel effet at risk
bon en effet tout à fait des bénéfices
aujourd'hui donc il faut il faut
absolument continuer mais voilà en
sachant que toute refaite acteur qui va
dans ce sens c'est que sur tous les
alors là c'est pas les mêmes taxes armes
et surtout les ex on a un recul qui est
quand même important maintenant ils sont
étudiés depuis très longtemps c'est un
diamant fins et par un équipement
vraiment puisque c'est préventif mais
qu'on connaît mieux et j'ai eu la chance
quand j'ai travaillé un petit peu en
pharmacovigilance de pouvoir étudier un
peu les effets indésirables des vaccins
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que voir
un fort recul
on a un bon de déclaration d'effets
indésirables donc ça veut dire quoi se
dire qu'un paquet ans qui sont graves
ça veut dire qu'on a beaucoup
d'informations sur les potentiels effets
indésirables des vaccins
et quand on les étudie on voit que comme
l'a dit monsieur malacarne ce sont des
effets qui ne secoue et grave du tout
dans ses fonctions des vagues au sein de
la rougeur au point d'injection ou d'un
syndrome grippal comme ce qu'on peut
observer parfois là avec ce vaccin
astrazeneca
c'est à dire un peu de fièvre un peu de
fatigue des maux de tête mais qui dure
pas plus d'une journée et qui sont
franchement au regard des risques et des
complications du coc vide
absolument concernant l'acte de la
vaccination antique vide à kevin
malacarne est ce que vous craignez que
ce dossier astrazeneca ne refroidissent
encore un peu plus les réticents à la
vaccination alors qu'elle est présentée
comme la seule issue possible à la crise
sanitaire et un des vaccins parmi
d'autres il se trouve que le il a été
pour l'instant privilégiée
en tout cas pour les soignants et
on a remarqué effectivement une
réticence d'une partie du personnel
soignant et je crois que physique
important d'un que voilà que la
communauté soignante dans son ensemble
rassure les personnes avec qui elle
serait encore un peu sceptique
et puis à se dire que voilà ça c'est pas
grave que même si pendant 24 48 heures
on va avoir une fatigue des quelques
courbatures et un peu de fièvre
on prend du paracétamol on fait en sorte
peut-être de le faire avant une journée
de repos et on se dit que c'est notre
devoir de soignants de le faire et que
grâce à ça eh bien on va pouvoir couper
les contamination nosocomiale qui sont
souvent très grave et qui va nous
permettre et bien les bases de limiter
le le le comment dire le le stress
hospitalier qui en ce moment
et puis ben de maintenir on va dire le
si possible les conditions dans lequel
on est pour le moment qu'ils sont on le
sait quand
qu'est ce qu'elle dit aujourd'hui le
personnel soignant de ses doutes qui
entourent le vaccin d'astrazeneca
je crois que la communauté soignante et
différentes 1 c'est certain tout le
monde et fayat on peut pas dire qu'il ya
100 % de personnes qui qui qui sont
encore vaccinés on en est loin que faut
qu'on y arrive
il ya encore de certaines réticences à
vaincre c'est vrai que je prends je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de soignants qui
maintenant on sait confiance aux files
heures alors qu' ils avaient ils avaient
peur de vous rappeler il ya quelques
mois le vaccin et rennes s'étaient enfin
voilà il ya énormément de réticences par
rapport à ce vaccin
on a vu que c'était un vaccin formidable
vraiment du goût de tout le monde veut
le finder mais il se trouve que les
études ont montré que pour l'instant en
tout cas et vu les doses qu'on a on l'a
on privilégie des pôles les populations
les plus fragiles avec le finder et donc
du coup l'attrait et l'écart est plutôt
donner aux pauvres aux soignants et
effectivement il y à quelques effets
secondaires mais qui sont bénard et donc
voilà il peut avoir une certaine
réticence en disant maman c'est pas
forcément envie demain d'avoir la fièvre
mais voilà enfin de l'enjeu dépasse bien
ce truc là et il faut
il faut prendre son courage à deux mains
et dire non je prends rendez vous il ya
de la place à ce moment à paris à
l'hôtel dieu
j'avais des infirmiers aujourd'hui qui
se sont inscrits ils ont des rendez-vous
pour le lendemain donc il ya de la place
on peut prendre rendez vous et il faut
le faire c'est notre devoir de soignants
ont peut-être revenir pour terminer
françois cravans crise sur le poids que
représente le vaccin astrazeneca dans la
stratégie française puisqu'il pourrait
théoriquement permettre aux termes des
livraisons de l'actionnaire un tiers de
la population
résultat le suspense serait ralentir la
vaccination et on n'est déjà pas très en
avance en france
est ce que c'est pour cette raison
justement qu'on évoque le calcul du
bénéfice risque
alors papa uniquement si j'essayais de
me faire dire que en fait on est prêts à
presque plus ou moins maîtrisés pour
maintenir le rythme des vaccinations
je vous réponds non il ya il ya une
réponse qui est scientifique qui dit que
le risque on ait accès à sion roupies y
en ait d'autres est acceptable c'est ça
le bénéfice tease et en plus de ça eh
bien il ya le rythme de la vaccination
avec la possibilité de mettre si ce
n'est une fin en tout cas un beau coup à
l'épidémie dc d'ici la fin du printemps
ou l'été
je pense que ces deux arguments quand
même poids on peut il faut continuer la
stratégie qui en place il faut continuer
d'accélérer encore comme le dit le
gouvernement et j'espère en effet comme
le dit monsieur malacarne que les les
soignants vont continuer à ce qu'on peut
on peut leur faire confiance
je peux interne c'est que évidemment on
comprend les réactions de chacun quand
on entend dire qui peut arriver en plus
des maladies thromboemboliques qui peut
être des mots qui font peur et qui
peuvent parfois être en effet des graves
parfois mois et on comprend que ça
d'un point de vue personnel on s'imagine
avoir la maladie voilà ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que quand on dit
qu'il n'ya pas c'est pas significatif
il n'y a pas de corrélation prouver ça
veut dire que c'est probablement des
gens des personnes
qui aurait eu cette maladie qu'ils aient
pris ou non le vaccin simplement en dans
la tempe et et s'avérait qu'ils les ont
eu 20 ans au cours après la après
l'injection
merci à tous les deux messieurs d'avoir
participé à ce débat ce soir sur arte
france françois krakowski médecin
spécialiste de santé publique et kevin
malacarne fondateur d'actions soit
infirmiers merci à tous les deux et à
bientôt